because I assume you guys watch a lot of
YouTube right I mean I'm not done I
watched and I'd keep my eye I watch
World of Warcraft lore videos
and Dragon Ball Z lore videos
that is something I love those videos I
love those what would happen if Goku was
reborn with all his pride Powers what
would happen if Goku died oh you're one
of those we found the Dragon Ball fan
and it makes so much sense now do you
watch the Power scaling videos
I hate them I hate them but I I I'm
never gonna have an anime
you could have an anime opinion and uh
would you anyone remembers the uh Game
Theory video that they put out being
like what would happen if these Nintendo
characters went had the coronavirus and
then I think later
yeah yes it's the title I think he
changed the title and he may have
deleted whole thing Matt Pat put a video
out like some [__] like what would
happen if if yeah Corona if these
characters got coronavirus what would
happen how would they would they [__]
survive or some [__]
I swear that was real
yes
and then you know I feel like they had
comments being like uh my grandma died
this is
it real game theory who will survive
censored or virus
oh
yeah
oh God that's [__] up so you changed
the time
is this an actual quote from the video
your grandmother who has diabetes and
hypertension definitely wouldn't survive
longer than Luigi was a super item no
that's not that's that why is everyone
commenting this there's no let me see
they're just making the same drugs we
made
[Music]
your grandmother who has diabetes
your grandmother is diabetes and
hypertension definitely wouldn't survive
longer than Luigi who has a super
heightened jump
[Laughter]
yeah
you're just like
[Music]
sometimes the video can be too topical
that's when you know you run that
[__] idea
I used to like Game Theory but you know
such Brave tics
yeah well you know what I mean he's just
trying to I think it's a nice video it's
more General
I think there was a time that game
theory was really fun and exciting yeah
and then I think it became when I was
[__] 12 maybe I think when Five
Nights at Freddy's came out I think it
became a different channel that peach
isn't [__] Mario she's [__] Luigi
yeah
I don't remember this one at all I think
I've seen a dragon ball with the uh
Dragon Ball series
what's the wildest Dragon Ball it's just
Dragon Ball fans yeah the problem it's
it's like a meme in the anime community
that Dragon Ball fans have like the
lowest IQ
I understand that because it's a very
simple [__] show oh he gets stronger
he's hair color changed
you know I don't know
I enjoy it because it's such a like
simple card I don't need to know if
[__] you know and [__] I don't
need to know that Australian accusations
I don't need to know that [__] you
know old mate uses guns with his what
are those things called Attack on Titan
there's 30 move again yeah maneuver gear
I've seen every episode I don't know why
I don't know why why are you acting like
you're not a weed
Attack on Titan recall out of everything
if you ask me questions I'll know but
off the top of the Dome I can't like I
think Chad's on his phone when he
watches [__] no yeah and by the way I
[__] hate it now like it's just what
wait what because they split up the last
best part over [__] a year and a half
okay okay
that pisses me the building is like
egregious yeah that pisses me I
definitely lost interest in not not the
because they did the one hour special
and then there's gonna be another one
hour special [__] knows how long to
actually end the show but the the season
before that was just kind of like why
just wait just release it all when it's
done why are you doing this well that
that's the first time I've ever just
read the Manga because I just didn't
want to wait any longer so now I know
the ending
I don't know the end I don't know I
don't know the ending basically they
have AIDS
they technically all do have titanes
they die after that okay well thank you
well is it eight years
I don't know oh my God is it gonna be
our worst episode
who watches it the most out of YouTube
Chad yeah oh okay I haven't watched
anime in a long time my problem is if I
pick something up I can't stop watching
it if I like it right why is that a
problem I got a job
just [__] face Chad just commenting on
anime
that would be amazing I get really
caught up in the relationships I'm like
can you guys just [__] like that's the
thing they never [__] you know what
my brother and sister as well
I think they're related so I don't know
adopted adopted
not really about blood yeah and then
there's some other like plotliner where
she's like oh she's meant to obey
everything he says because she's like
the Japanese like uh she's like the
Japanese
so there's different nations and she's
from like the ancient Japanese uh Island
I [__] don't know every time you say
Japanese he's like dead eye contact with
me I don't know
can I say it can I say the thing
I have another Grog please
get them all out of strum all around you
Max what's your uh what would you say is
your favorite anime I've never seen one
no that's [__] that's a [__] one
okay this is like um on uh when P when
you guys have PewDiePie on yeah I can
think of his death knight
oh yeah let's get out of it that show
also got [__] um wait wait wait I did
I did like death note yeah um that was
like the probably the first proper anime
when I was like an angsty teen yeah I
think I think it was everyone's first
um but I haven't I feel like these great
ones are [__] [__]
no they're good for like I haven't I
haven't tried a grape one yet okay
they're all very sweet they are very
sweet we've got to tone them back a
little bit uh can I try the peach one's
the bird Peach one's good yeah this
one's really sweet it's good for like
we're gonna we're gonna bring the
flavoring down on this this is why we
don't like because it's bit too strong
okay do you want it no no okay okay so
so Death Note you'd say
uh trying to think uh Pokemon
I did not watching what do you mean I
did not [__] watch the actual shirt
but you didn't no I mean like it's still
going I mean they finished it yeah Ash
is like dead now yeah yeah yeah
finishing it entirely though well
they're finishing
[__] Naruto bro oh I did watch uh
I've watched a lot of that yeah
um did you finish it no
I think it was such like the pain all
right you stopped at the good where you
stopped a good one yeah you're being
pissed off about the animation in some
of those scenes so I thought it was I
thought I liked it oh
there's like goofy animation in one of
the pain fights oh like really pissed
off is that the screenshot of like paint
space yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I really
like I really like the animation in that
but yeah I don't know anything about
Naruto um yeah he's never seen an hour
is this an anime podcast you know you've
seen every anime
okay it's so goddamn long
um but uh one punch one punch season one
I remember I really like this like
probably the most recent like proper
thing yeah and what was what's the other
show that that guy did mob cycle
yeah
animation is [__] yeah fantastic yeah
have you guys ever Read Manga I have
read a couple of One Piece
three pieces
never ending so it's still going that is
still going I get hyper focused on like
specific things yeah at one point I was
like oh I'm obsessed with uh One Piece
manga even though I hadn't like read
that many right but ahead of time I like
bought like so oh my God I was like I'm
gonna read through these and they're
just sitting on the shelf and it's like
11 or 12 or something it's like one
twentieth from mango yeah I think it's
on like chapter
1100 volume 104 I think yeah yeah yes
like over a thousand chapters but it's
it's ending I swear to God within the
minute
10 years confirmed what's the longest
running anime ever
Hey Arthur
[Applause]
and if you look at the original books
his head's longer and more [__] up it
looks like an actual but then when they
made it into the middle anime yeah
exactly they're like round that's a good
show